[Musique]
tous quand on regarde l'amour est dans
le pré où une ambition intime il est
impossible de ne pas avoir envie que
karine lemarchand devienne notre ami
toujours souriante intéressé aux autres
est pourvu de second degré l'animatrice
fait l'unanimité ça commence fort
pourtant selon certains la vraie karine
lemarchand serait dans la vie assez loin
de l'image positive et sympathique
qu'elle véhicule à la télévision
selon le magazine public qui lui
consacre un article l'animatrice de m6
serait en coulisses une vraie diva des
sources proches de la star révèle elle
arrive avec son chauffeur personnel tout
le monde attend que madame soit prêt
pendant plus d'une heure et pique une
crise à sa coiffeuse les proches qui
semble très critique à ton sujet quand
certains lui reprochent de ne pas
supporter que les autres boivent de
l'alcool en sa présence d'autres vont
plus loin pénible avec les équipes et
faussement amicales avec les
agriculteurs une punchline qui fait mal
et les sources anonymes ne sont pas les
seuls à s'exprimer sur le comportement
parfois déplacée de karine le marchand
comme guillaume candidats de l'amour est
dans le pré qui avait livré un
témoignage pour le moins édifiant
quand je me confie son adolescence
difficile et le fait que j'ai pensé au
suicide est là la petite larme à l'oeil
mais quand la productrice lui dit que
c'est dans la boîte elles se lavent et
rigole des propos qui font mal alors
karine lemarchand une animatrice
ingérable en coulisses
[Applaudissements]
ça vous est ce que ça vous choque ce
genre de révélations est ce que vous
avez envie de le savoir ça d'ailleurs
parce que tu es quand on sait quand on
est un indicateur et non mais pourquoi
pas mais ça me choque
le fait que ce soit un fake ou le fait
qu'on le voue le fait qu'on dise qu'on
dise qu'on le rêve à lui qu'on a révèle
non mais c'est vrai que les gens qui
regardent l'émission qu'elle soit sympa
ou pas la limite on s'en fout et je ne
fais pas la liste de ceux qui sont
sympas et l'écran et des [ __ ] y en a
beaucoup alors qui croire alors aussi un
magazine voilà quelques mois pour ça que
moi je n'ai pas karine lemarchand
personnel a donc publiquement chèque de
temps en temps c'est vrai c'est pas vrai
donc je n'ai pas la vie puisque je la
connais pas donc je ne peux pas croire
public pour le monde parce que je ne
sais pas je la connais pas après
quand je vois cette photo c'est par
claire
c'est vrai que dans le métier c'est
raide avec vous ça se dire ça se dit
voilà il
ya deux choses que je voudrais dire
c'est que avec karine on se connaît un
petit peu on sent encore croiser
dimanche dernier dans un restaurant
c'était quelqu'un d'extrêmement charmant
avec moi et tout le personnel et tous
les gens qui lui parlait après faut pas
oublier que sur les émissions de télé il
ya ce qu'on appelle les rushs c'est à
dire que quand vous voyez une émission
qui est diffusée il ya tout qui est mis
en boîte de toute façon même quand on ne
dit pas ça tourne attention action voilà
un peu comme le cinéma donc si un moment
donné il ya des images qui existent que
les personnes les montrer qu'on le
prouve une bonne fois pour toutes les
chances à des notions de tribunal à
l'ajax d'arrêt contre lui de roche qui
n'est pas l'émission si m franchement si
on se sont
cependant
je suis pas donc j'ai pas le seul les
sources anonymes d'un magasin comme
public voilà on sait on sait voilà ça
reste des attentes et s'est montré bien
que ces images elles sortiront jamais
même s'il n'a pas fait ressortir ces
images par mois là c'est la tête de
liste de deux de leurs chaînes karina
marche à tête de gondole la tête de
gondole wiba excusez-moi j'ai fait de
même à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
l'arrosage on constate effectivement
assez du dominion va pas fort moi ce que
je constate c'est que c'est pas la
première fois que je dis sur karine
lemarchand que ça a été dit dans des
magazines télé dans des magazines people
ça a été dit dans télé star sida
tu te décris
après l'événement que les gens soient
épouvantable très bien mais moi les gens
qui nous regardent ils ont menacé
la première près ils sont malhonnêtes
habite actuellement mais bon ça y est
c'est la première question qu'on pose
aux gens moi que je sais qu'à chaque
darwish pas des gens et visera alors il
est vraiment sympa
vraiment
s'intéressent maintenant après ces
enquêtes de jugement de valeur elles
sont un peu dangereuse parce que excusez
moi toutes les personnes qui font de la
télé on est tous arrivé des fois un peu
mal luné ou avec des combats mais jamais
j'apprécie
mais parce qu'on est des n'est pas trop
lui même et je m'inclus pas dedans mais
où il est un être humain
peut-être excusez moi du terme et peut
être désagréable pour certains et en
fait c'était pas des s'était pas contre
eux mais des fonds seront pas forcément
contre la pression etc et on est mal
jugé non alors oui il faut faire
attention mais une personnalité publique
doit faire encore plus les attentions
qu'une personne qui n'est pas public
justement parce qu'elle est jugé
beaucoup plus vite aussi vous souffle
que tu n'as pas tous les sons de cloches
moi j'ai discuté et très franchement
avec de nombreux agriculteurs ayant
participé à la mort d'un et est dans le
pré et tous sont unanimes concernant le
comportement
excellent willis ont fait géniale de
quesnel et marche en avant c'est
pourquoi après l'émission c'est vrai
qu'en t'exploser t'es face à la critique
mais vouloir se faire au cas de se faire
coiffer c'est pas un caprice c'est du
professeur généralement tétouan en loge
maxi l'art c'est un amour c'est
vraiment sympa ça toujours été comme ça
a mené pas qu'ils avaient louis de funès
d'accord louis de funès
là bas je veux bien qu'on dise n'importe
quoi mais
bien qu'à mon époque de général de
gaulle
et - 80 ans mais ces pages et outreau
j'aime et où
beaucoup de funès moi la paix à son âme
et franchement honnêtement donc si je
revenais sur lui il était odieux et ça
n'a aucun sens n'empêche pas qu'il est
très talentueux ces fouilles étaient pas
au dieu était juste sinistre était bien
d'accueillir ses dires sais pas